[Music]
[Applause]
he's Ross delinger he's been busy Yahoo
sports senior writer covering college
football and Michigan's in a little bit
of trouble or at least they appear to be
in a little bit of trouble Ross joining
us now Ross how'd this story come to
light uh let's see it happen pretty
quickly as these things do um it was uh
Wednesday late afternoon kind of uh we
got a tip at Yahoo Dan wetzell and I
about it um and uh started to pursue it
and Wednesday night didn't really have
it but we understood what happened which
was the NCAA had started an
investigation into Michigan uh a
separate investigation from the one they
were already conducting and they had
alerted the big 10 on late Wednesday
afternoon um or Wednesday evening and
then the in the Big 10 um the bigt
alerted Michigan's opponents future
opponents including Michigan State so
that's kind of how the word uh leaked
out so to speak walk me through the
accusations well the main act you know
sign stealing uh is pretty prevalent in
college football um it's uh it's not
illegal it's not against NCA rules um to
steal uh a team signs from the broadcast
or during a game in signaling them in I
mean none of that is illegal what is
illegal in this situation specifically
uh is how the signs were stolen um in in
1994 so this goes back almost 30 years
the NCAA implemented a rule prohibiting
in-person scouting at Future opponents
games and the theory is that Michigan um
is a obtaining the this play or sign
stealing information right from uh from
attending in-person games so scouting
games which again was illegal so that's
kind of the Focus right now but plenty
of teams you know steal signals right I
Clemson has been known for for years in
in Brent venables uh and it's no secret
among the coaching Community for being
really Adept at ingame stealing of signs
and maybe preparing beforehand through
broadcast and stuff but obviously the
NCA has some kind of credible evidence
uh that Michigan got this in uh let's
say ilicit illicit ways different ways
than just ingame or from the broadcast
how big a deal is
this well you know that is a great
question um
and it depends on who you ask uh there
there are certainly several people
who kind of roll their eyes at this uh
even knowing that Michigan could have
done something that others don't
normally do to get signs they kind of
put their hands up and say what's the
big deal here doesn't the NCAA have
other things to to do um but obviously
this this has been going on for at least
a year it goes back to at least last
season and it started to spread through
the Big 10 and Big 10 coaching Community
about Michigan's uh expert on staff in
in stealing signs and it did you know
change the way certainly they coach
right they uh they change instead of
signaling in plays a lot of teams
started using wristbands instead or
huddling instead so it does have an
impact but you're it's a great question
and a lot of people kind of wonder why
the NCA is uh wasting their time Jim
Harbaugh said he knows nothing about
this but the report is the NCA wants to
get the computer or has the computer of
somebody who is uh I guess unofficially
on the staff at Michigan does that kind
of characterize the situation yeah
there's a uh there's an analyst and we
we we learned some of this information
yesterday uh he's a kind of a very
low-level analyst uh was in the Navy
actually Conor stallions uh has since
his name kind has gotten out he has
since scrubbed all of his social media
which probably is uh um some kind of
indictment uh on the fact that he is
involved and I actually have pictures of
him on the sideline signaling in plays
um or or signaling in the signs of what
the opposing coach is doing which again
isn't completely rare right we've seen
it but it's how he got that information
how he got these these signals from the
opponent um it's clearly done more than
just the normal ways uh in the NCA is
certain looking into that like you said
ESPN had reported that they're looking
into his computer and such um but but
there it is a it is an obvious kind of
known thing in the in the Big 10 at
schools in the Big 10 that this is the
person that stands on the sideline next
to Jesse Mentor the defensive
coordinator in Jim Harbaugh and does
gesture uh when uh when the offense uh
before the offense takes a snap what are
you guys working on today you and Dan
wenton well this right here right I mean
ESPN had some of it last night uh about
about the analyst uh who signals in the
plays we have a little more info about
this situation you know uh he he is
apparently is at the center of kind of
this investigation and he is a guy that
I think uh again within the the Big 10
coaching ranks uh they they pointed
toward him as as being the the signaler
and a lot of schools this this this
season alone two two schools that
Michigan played uh went from the most
part went without signaling in the game
because they knew that this was
apparently a thing that Michigan did and
they just used the wristbands uh so it's
just another follow story on exactly
what's going on here and what's to come
can it affect Michigan this
year well the NCAA Dan oper oper Ates
slowly uh the only I like to say the
only body that operates slower is
Congress and and now the NCA and
Congress have come together right uh I
was just at my ninth nil hearing earlier
uh earlier this week here on I live in
DC here on Capitol Hill and uh so things
things work slowly though in the NCAA
where where are we with nil and and the
government's involvement in
this well the NCA once the government uh
involved which is a rarity right and
they've been they've been encouraging
Congress for four years now to to
produce some kind of federal law um that
governs nil but the attention Dan has
really turned away from from nil and I
wrote about this earlier this week at
Yahoo after the hearing is that the the
focus instead of nil has really been on
these court cases in the the employment
athlete employment which is most would
say is on the way that athletes will be
consider Ed employees at some point by
the courts and now the NCAA instead of
encouraging Congress just for an nil
bill they want a bill that protects them
from the courts that protects their
athletes they say from being employeed
so that's kind of the main focus right
now well I know you got a busy weekend
Ross thanks for spending some time with
us yeah then thank you Ross delinger
he's a senior writer covering college
football Yahoo sports he and Dan Wetzel
do wonderful John